I haven't been able to watch a video
back properly because it just it breaks
my heart hearing like my voice and how
upset I was and it I'm still upset I'm
still heartbroken by the fact that
they'd removed me from my three month
old baby who has no idea that of what's
going on well innocent until proven
guilty they see us as guilty and
innocent you know FBI top ten yeah the
way they came out the car was as if
we're FBI top ten when are they ever
gonna openly say that we stopped them
because they were black they're not
going to say that because to them the
the UK's not racist but the UK is very
racists and it's just it's heartbreaking
to know that if it's not us it's gonna
be somebody else you know it's gonna be
a week it's a weekly thing it's not it's
not you know once a month this a weekly
thing that happens at a black man it
stops in a car because he looked
suspicious or they can smell cannabis
that's outrageous it's disgusting
it's the first time you know we can move
on from here
but it's not the second not the further
the fourth not the fifth it's numerous
occasions you know and I need to have
both of my cars I get stopped for what
reason because I look like somebody
after or I look like I I do drugs or I
look like I can't afford a decent car
well as we're saying the Commissioner of
the Metropolitan Police Cressida dick
has always maintained that the net are
not racist as I say they have
consistently said there was no
wrongdoing in this specific incident
they say that the car was driving away
from them at speed and a statement the
Met Police say officers witnessed a
vehicle with blacked-out windows was
driving suspiciously including driving
on the wrong side of the road they
indicated for it to stop but it failed
to do so and made off at speed the
officers caught up with a vehicle when
it stopped on land Hill Road the driver
initially refused to get out of the car
each stop they say is that will on its
own merits at the discretion of
individual officers involved and they go
on to say that officers have to make
these judgment calls regularly on a
daily basis often in differ
called circumstances and that they
reviewed both footage from social media
and the body-worn video of the officers
and a satisfied that there is no concern
around the officers conduct in his worth
saying that Bianca Williams and her
partner both refute that they were
driving on the wrong side of the road
all that their vehicle was speeding away
from police officers but as I say you
know this footage clearly a very
emotional scene are unfolding you can
hear the officers asking the people in
the car to remain calm but appearing to
pull them from out the car we know that
the independent office for police
conduct have said that they are looking
into this but as yet no formal
investigation has been launched